[Music]
what's up everybody brandon johnson here
again and today we're taking a look at
five patterns and sounds of bluegrass
guitar now these five guitar techniques
that i've picked up over the years are a
great way to kind of make your guitar
playing sound a little bit more like
blue grass and these techniques you can
add to really just kind of a basic
foundational knowledge of the guitar
like open chords maybe just basic
soloing some things that you know most
guitar players out there can probably
integrate into their current skill set
now these five techniques are the g run
the chuck alternating bass riffing off
the octave and passing runs and lead-in
runs now these bluegrass guitar
techniques can kind of be used on their
own whether you're playing lead melody
or even rhythm guitar but first let's
take a look at a couple of these
techniques in detail and specifically
how you can integrate them into your
playing starting with the famous g run
all right so the first and probably most
common sound you're going to hear in
bluegrass guitar is what's called the g
run now the g run sounds like this
[Music]
now there are countless variations on
this famous lick and if you check out my
video on the g run you can learn several
different examples of this and you can
use this in a bunch of different ways
it's used on its own as kind of a an
intro or an outro it can be used as part
of solos that lick is super iconic and
it really signals to the listener that
you know this is bluegrass music and
it's fairly useful because it starts on
the g note
or the root note and it ends on the g
note or the root note if you're playing
a g
now that same run in c
[Music]
it's the exact same notes just over a c
chord and it has the same
similarities it starts on the c
and ends on the c
and the second most common sound and
pattern in bluegrass music is what's
called the chuck so the chuck is simply
a sound that's created by the downstroke
of a pick now it's not this is not
unique to guitar you can chuck on a
mandolin you can chuck on a banjo
basically any instrument that's strummed
even a dobro you can do this basic kind
of chuck sound and the way it's used is
it's used on the offbeat as a way to
kind of accent the bass or to kind of
you know give it a little bit of
rhythmic interest and that's a really
really easy way to kind of make your
rhythm playing sound like bluegrass now
what's important here is to really
capture the sound
of the pick hitting the strings
and that's really important to kind of
[Music]
kind of create that chuck in your rhythm
play
[Music]
and what you'll notice there is i'm
playing sort of the root note of the
chord on the one or on the quarter note
and then i'm playing the down stroke or
the chuck on the offbeat
which is generally kind of just
strumming out the rest of the chord now
the next sound and pattern of bluegrass
guitar is what's called alternating bass
and this is kind of a general concept
that you can use in your rhythm playing
and it involves kind of playing bass
over your chords or bass notes over the
chords that kind of emulate the bass
player and a lot of times what the bass
player does is on the quarter note or on
the off beat depending on the tune they
will often alternate between the root
note of the chord in this case a c
and the fifth of the chord so the fifth
of the chord the fifth of c is going to
be a g
[Music]
so what you'll do is you'll alternate
kind of between those two bass notes
those are kind of bass notes because
they're in the lower register of the
guitar
while you're playing your bluegrass
rhythm
[Music]
you'll notice what i'm doing there is
i'm actually physically moving my finger
from the root note to the fifth note
or the c note to the g note
and one way you can kind of simplify
that is you can play this sort of
modified c chord here so a normal c
chord would look like this
and with this modified alternating bass
type chord you can take your root note
or your ring finger here and put it on
the third fret low e which is a g
and then with your little finger
you can place it back down on the root
note
you're left with this kind of a chord
and then you can play your alternating
bass without having to move your finger
[Music]
and of course there's many many
different ways to play alternating bass
and each chord is going to be different
but the general rule of thumb is that
you're going to alternate between the
root note of the chord and the fifth of
the chord so if we look at a d for
example the root of d is d
and you can use that open d string there
if you're playing the d chord out of the
open position
and then your fifth is going to be an a
so you'll alternate between the d and
the a
[Music]
and the next sound and pattern of
bluegrass guitar is what i like to call
riffing off the octave and so what
you're doing here is you're playing a
very specific pattern
which is making use of the same note in
a different position on the neck
so if we look at a g chord here this is
probably the most common example you'll
hear this a lot as an intro or even as
part of a solo
[Music]
so what you're doing is you're using the
same note the open g in a different
position on the neck right so we have
our our g note here
and then right underneath it is an open
g
and what you're doing is you're
syncopating between those two strings
and adding in a slide so the slide is
going to come in from the third fret d
to the fifth fret d
and then you're going to hit that open g
on a down stroke
followed by an upstroke
and then play that g on the d string on
a down stroke
and you can kind of create a pattern
here that you can use as an intro or as
part of a solo but it's something that
is very common in bluegrass music and
it's going to make your
guitar playing you know kind of sound
like bluegrass
[Music]
another cool way to do that if you don't
want to do the slide the full three fret
slide you can just kind of do a little
bit of a hammer on
[Music]
what i'm doing there is i'm playing with
my middle finger fourth fret d
and then hammering on with my ring
finger
on the fifth fret d
[Music]
and of course you can do that in other
keys as well and it really works best if
you have the root note of that chord
available as an open string
right underneath it so for example we
could do this in d as well
[Music]
or we can do it in a
and the last sound and pattern of
bluegrass guitar of course there's many
but this is probably one of the more
common ones that you'll hear are passing
runs and lead-in runs so a lot of times
rhythm guitar players in bluegrass style
music will add in a lot of
embellishments in between the chord
changes so for example if you're playing
a g to a d
[Music]
so you'll notice there is that i'm kind
of just riffing right before i go into
the d chord i kind of play just a little
two note or three note riff
and in this case it's going to be if
we're starting on a g chord it's going
to be an open a
second fret a
[Music]
open a again followed by a quick open d
which is going to be the root note of
the d chord so you're sort of playing a
run or riffing into the d chord and
landing on the d note
[Music]
all right now let's try to combine these
five bluegrass guitar concepts
[Music]
thanks for checking out this lesson
today there's a lot more where that came
from on my website
brandonjohnsonguitar.com
where i have every lesson i've ever made
including the full complete lesson video
for every single tune
backing tracks tab sheets and sound
slice integration level up your guitar
playing and join the community at
brandonjohnsonguitar.com
we'll see you there
[Music]
you